some people like you know what we're all
nobody's getting out of this
alive we're all you know what i mean if
we're lucky we live to 117 like that
lady
who just beat covet in france or
wherever i mean the queen is
the queen's almost a hundred margaret
lived till 100 and
something you know it's ridiculous yeah
so so then we are
uh uh uh midlife at the moment if we're
and but the point is like
we've there was a moment when when lord
of the rings won best
picture that
moment i
i was like i can i feel like i've made a
contribution to the
to the world i feel like i've done like
if i die now
i can die at peace because i i did
something
and i think teachers and nurses nurses
and firefighters like if whatever your
thing is if you if you live and it
doesn't have to be epic
you know it's like some people my wife i
remember when we first got together we
were sitting in the bathtub
with my gorgeous girlfriend at the time
and uh you know she was this uh
she's sexy and always still is of course
you're right you're sitting in the
bathtub with your wife yes
obviously naked you know yeah we take
baths naked okay i just wanted to make
sure because you never know what i'm
saying thanks i'm just painting a
picture for you man
we just had our fit our 30th first date
anniversary
uh on the 13th wow yeah and you're gonna
be
50 in a week and that'll be 50 is it a
week yeah yeah yeah holy [ __ ] buddy life
but you already made a contribution so
who cares
whatever you're doing that's the thing
well we were sitting we were in this
bathtub
and i was i proposed to her the first
minute i met her i was like
you know the fact that she even looked
twice at me was ridiculous like clearly
she had some mental defects because
you can't be that gorgeous and that
stupid like
to go for me i'm like this [ __ ] actor
guy running around
and uh and and we're there and she's
from indiana her dad was a firefighter i
grew up in indiana
indiana's beautiful right and and you
know but she was she was small town
people she was working actually in
beverly hills at the time
at a commercial agency that's how we met
but but her mentality
as sophisticated as she was she was like
real people
you know she's like a normal so
what she means means what she says like
you know does it can see
uh artifice for what it is you know like
enjoys
things that are exciting and and you
know whatever but but has a sense of
perspective about the world it's just a
world view i know you know
that that some people have a way of a
way of being a settledness she came from
a
a family like her mom died when she was
three
her dad cycled through a lot of
different women um
she uh there was there was a lot of
drama
in her early life and it just it just
what came out of that was a person who
was like you know what i
that can define me or i i can be me you
know what though what i just figured out
what you just said
her dad died when she was uh or her mom
died when she was three
her dad uh you know was a flanderer you
know with women coming in and out
and then my thought is then she sees you
and for some reason you're already in
the bathtub when she sees you
and she has she looks at you and says
this because this guy you have a
certain disposition that
gives comfort to people you are
comforting sean
and i think that that's a big part of
let me am i wrong she
just felt like you are a humble uh man
who could give her other things besides
pleasure
i think i was both a nurturing
type figure like a stable person because
i was all in from the second i met her
you know i mean there was no how fast
come on people say that but how fast
were you all
in five minutes five minutes
maybe you say maybe not
her brother worked her late brother
worked at the uh
actually her late brother carrington
that's
he painted that oh wow that's his
painting he's a painter
um but he uh he worked down the hall
she worked in the celebrity side and he
worked in the uh what non-celebrity side
i don't know whatever but
um he came in like five minutes after we
met
and she said this is my brother
carrington and i stood up and said
carrington it's a pleasure to meet you
may have permission to marry your sister
and he she was just uh had broken up
with someone
that he did not like so he was like sure
just like that he just sold her out i'm
like damn he's kind of like
don't trust that guy now how many dates
before
you actually proposed uh how long was it
a year i think like on my knee with a
ring formal proposal was three months